pleasure to welcome
Mitch broad state digital archives
fantastic archetypes
Watford organization attended to because
all the musicians were partners and
stuff man
meaning they don't anything down
everything down that is you know a
miracle I think that it still exists but
that is the legacy that we've inherited
a material that we have towards our
printed programs
musician rosters
scores marks floors particular mark
scores I'd like to
parts are five incisions themselves
while sitting on stage letters
correspondence telegrams
finances of all sorts photographs
newspaper clippings
and subscriber list and seat location
lists and of course we have all kinds on
video 7,000 hours
19:34 mine with their weekly Sunday
broadcast was considered America's
Orchestra
well and many on the road as well this
is a very brief overview of the kind of
insurer we have but I'd like us to get
through with the other presentations
where's this is a very unique kind of
collection there in terms of its depth
and breadth and what it allows us to do
is to look at a single burner event or
experience from a multitude of Vantage
Awards so as you can see from that those
examples of those documents you can
understand or have an idea about the
concert from 1842 from the perspective
of the conductor
No
in that desert
has been a first impact or not
- but - you know that night premiere and
on and on and on so there are all kinds
of future and rich possibilities of
research to take place so we managed
they thought about nice
it was time to consider
and due to a major very generous grant
we
Foundation some of the goals for
digitisation a bit of a rock is possible
around the world or learning new things
but for me the major value
digitized as much as we would like to
say oh we met before digitized only 20
bothered with organization but back here
and we dis nice base and you can say
whatever the hell is paper over here
back to 32 and our questions say 2003 on
the digitisation digitized that'll just
be a different question I really think
that in about 40 years if we don't
digitize past our stories
and so it is really figure out how to
bring the past to migrate up justice
even with all of our auditor tapes it's
just we do know that audio material
migrate forward and so that it's
tourists still lips so like a future
although I'd like to show a little video
that we did which is called the vision
of the future
performing 15,000 concerts more concerts
than any other symphony orchestra in the
world creates a lot of history since its
first concert in 1842 the Philharmonic
has saved scores musician rosters
newspaper clippings letters committee
minutes finance sheets subscriber lists
and every program but the Philharmonic
is even more than a group of great
musicians performing great works of
music it is a reflection of the cultural
social and political movements of our
times whether it's the memorial concerts
for our fallen presidents Abraham
Lincoln JFK or striving for a living
wage and better working conditions
embracing women's suffrage or its varied
reactions to war from the
mexican-american in 1846 to Vietnam to
embarking on a mission for peace during
the Cold War and as new media such as
recordings radio home movies and
television became popular the
Philharmonic's collections expanded to
include these forms of documentation as
well
the Philharmonic archives has always
been an invaluable resource enticing
scholars musicians students and music
lovers around the world to visit its
reading room so would it be of interest
to digitize the archival treasures
making them available over the Internet
not only of interest but it will be a
necessity if I would be in charge of an
institution like that I would take this
decision immediately and radically in
less than three years
1.3 million pages of archival documents
will be digitized and made available for
research over the Internet with the
generous support of the Leon levy
foundation the archives embarks on a new
journey this time taking the archives to
anyone anywhere at any time
it begins in 1943 or what we call the
International era when the United States
emerges as a world power in New York
City its cultural capital the center of
wealth entertainment television
recording art and baseball when Leonard
Bernstein makes his pinch-hitting debut
Brunel Valter who was to have conducted
this afternoon his ill and his place
will be taken by the young american-born
assistant conductor of the Philharmonic
symphony Leonard Bernstein when the
Philharmonic becomes an international
touring sensation when the orchestra
opens Lincoln Center for the Performing
Arts and the young people's concerts are
broadcast on prime-time television my
dear young friends well this is a
treasure that you have here that any
conducting student any musicology
student and the enthusiast if they can
just go online and get Marla's
Corrections the difference is not only
in the ease of studying these treasures
but in how they can be searched the
digital archives brings together a
variety of material about a single topic
allowing for new revelations to see the
printed program listen to the broadcast
while following along in the score that
was on the podium that day consult the
managers backstage planning memos and
review the critics comments all of this
provides an unparalleled research
experience what an impact it can make
the point is for me to make the people
believe that this part of their
treasures they have is nowhere in the
world over the next 10 years the vision
of the future is to make the remaining
archive collections available that's 8
million pages of documents and nearly
seven thousand hours of audio and video
all about a single institution that
began in 1842 you know it's it's an
amazing tradition what it means though
is institutionally there's a collective
memory of really some of the most
exciting music making that has happened
and that's what makes an orchestra great
you know a new member comes in has never
played with Leonard Bernstein but it
doesn't take long before something
that's in the walls or in the air around
the orchestra seeps in and they become
part of this continuum and they're very
few orchestras that can boast this this
history and tradition today we are
making available collections that go
back several generations by the Year
2060 musicians scholars students and
music lovers worldwide will access the
materials that are born digital today
three centuries of history and Counting
the goal of the digital archives was in
its presentation what was paramount in
that was that we presented the material
in context for those who've done a lot
of research in online and in digital
collections there are many times he'll
you'll find a page but she won't have
any idea how it relates to anything else
so it was it was essential to us to
create something that would not only
just show it in context but would also
show the connections because as you can
see there are so many different vantage
points and from each one you might learn
something slightly different from this
so and this is although you could do
that in sort of the analog stage of the
material sitting at the reading room
table it's very hard it's very hard to
keep track of all of that so for
instance we'll just show an example of
this
Bernstein's debut program which you
didn't see before and you heard actually
the introduction you know you want to
dates
so Bernstein November 14 43 I should
also step back just a second and explain
mine and we start in 1943 and not in
1842 I I would have started in 1840 to
discuss up
I love the nineteenth century but I had
a group of scholars librarians musicians
musicologist journalists even who sat
around and talked about what would be
the most valued right now in research
and it was very interesting the amazing
incredibly compelling argument that
post-world war two New York was
underrepresented in original source
material and it was also the era under
Burnside and so with his mark scores it
was just too great an opportunity not
the sort of embracing start there so we
started kind of in the middle right
there at the tail end that puts
available we had a 40 to 50 year closure
policy in the archives and so 1970 is is
the top end with what's available right
now so if we go here and you can search
I mean all these facets that we have on
the left we went back and forth a lot on
what how things would be represented in
terms of searching but we went with a
single search window and and then you
can refine by the facets that come up on
the side but right now so you go to
Leonard Bernstein's
so Leonard Bernstein's debut and we'll
explore the document
first and this also allowed us this time
period to test certain assumptions about
the audio-video we don't have as you can
see before from the video that we're
going to be making them available that's
our hope but that is a very different
prospect than what we're doing right now
with the paper but this allows us then
to show how the video audio would be
used in different ways
United States Rubber Company identified
through the Carnegie Hall to hear a
concert of the North Carolina Symphony
Orchestra which art origins music
director think about it that we have a
radio broadcast isn't sending you back
to to the 1930s and with every Sunday
was a broadcast so the amount of
material that we have to put up is
really quite amazing
they also say besides the printed
program the librarian or the radio
engineer would it break down on the
actual timing so this is another
perspective on that event and then also
being an assuming because it was
important that the quality of the
material would be as good as possible
and it really is beautiful there have
been many kinds of letters which I could
no longer read in the folder which by
really zooming in now especially those
on some of faxes that were confronted
with now you can kind of see them but so
how to relate this to other material
that we might have so for instance if we
go back out and go into view details you
know this is where you would go to see
what are you suggested materials that
link into this program and this needs to
be refined better in terms of parts in
are no images and business documents but
for instance a score so there is a
natural linkage that's going on there
with the shoe and Manfred which was the
first score on on the program and if we
link here
and they'll view this well here we have
different things so down below this is
the score that actually that Leonard
bernstone actually used on November 14th
1943 and then here the actual sets of
parts that were used by the musicians
but simply go back up to the score it so
it depends on your point of view you
know if you're a flute player that wants
to know how player that they did this
work you might just look into that part
and see what's going on or here then we
could also and if you click on to the
music then instead of the entire
movement broadcast so this is what's
used
keep consuming on the canary diamond
this also has out mr. Bernstein's
you know many little annotations are
just the thing some discovered such as
who's read Byron lately
and those are all very bright you didn't
expect that to be shared so it's very
interesting to look at your scores but
you can go on here and right now we
record the orchestra and 24 tracks
because if you know what that means that
you know in the years when you know
listen to that broadcast it's made
available you can actually isolate we
can't do these analyses are not even
stereo reductions but you'll be able to
do that it would be remarkable how much
more granular it will get and then if we
go back to the search results
we have a business document
that comes up when you search
Bernstein's time period and here's the
memo that managers sent to the payroll
administrator to paid mr. Bernstein
notifying he's been hired he's going to
have eight hundred twenty-five dollars a
week the handwritten notes down below or
whatever really and do we do we digitize
because he we can't take the time you
forget whether it's relevant or
important we do everything in
photography so it's really very
inexpensive to take that shot so we just
do it off but on some of these for
instance and
here is you know how many weeks is he
engaged for 29 and should we charge him
charge it to a conductor and orchestra
and the manager says oh let him be a
conductor so this is that very kind of
never figuring out something to do with
the dollars there but this whole full
event deals with other things but this
is the first memo and that we don't
describe at the item level we described
at the folder level we don't have it
would never get done with probably if we
describe the item so you know
descriptions are always from fine right
we always have a backlog so this will be
refined in future so and then of course
there's here in this case one more as a
photograph
and so this is the photograph from his
debut when he's being congratulated
backstage suits a little too big for him
and we have tags would you face tagging
on ISA which is what we would go forward
with identifying all of our photographs
from now on when we incorporate all the
digital material now within the same
system as we keep the digital archives
digital archives is a repository that
everything will get fed into that's the
goal so going back out to this and after
looking at the site of course
digitisation is the easiest part taking
any picture and getting it put into some
sort of presentation description
presentation are very hard but it was a
whole new world for us to figure out
what are the legal rights that we have
to deal with here as I said we've been
making things accessible for 20 years at
mint any researcher that walked into our
reading room and we could show them this
material it was there for them so what's
the difference why can't we still be
doing that there and so a few years ago
I asked
property lawyer here in professor here
at Columbia to give us her best wisdom
and actually it's been incredibly
helpful in in what we have to do and I
don't know if you wants to show some
scores in this sort of thing or we can
go back listen
let's show let's show a couple scores
and what the language was of the of the
so the main question was
we're only cleanup marked parts mark
parts mark scores we are not putting up
scores we will in 19th century but we're
not putting up scores that are anything
other than mark why why you come here is
to see the interpreters marketers who
don't come here if you wanted to see a
major score so that is a significant
difference that we emphasize and as you
can see we are protecting the underlying
and this is a statement that we worked
hard at to make sure but now with parts
available we've just made parts
available in the last few months it's
very interesting to us that there's a
different sensitivity about parts vs.
scores even though it's the same
intellectual continent this is something
that
see where this takes us but we've made
all of these available and I really
wasn't sure what the fair use issues
would be around these kinds of things
but Jane if you want to talk about that
thanks very much this is a wonderful and
great exciting project I guess I will
start with that reading room because
before digital what the archives does
raises no copyright issues because the
the owner of a physical copy of a work
whether it's a library of archives or
anybody has the right to publicly
display that physical topic so making
available to anybody who walks into the
reading room all those scores parts
newspaper clippings and so forth doesn't
pose any copyright problems the
copyright problems come in when you
start to making copies and make those
copies available by remote transmission
there's the goal here because the
copyright law gives the copyright owner
certain exclusive rights those include
the rights to make copies to reproduce
the work in copies to publicly display
the work by transmission physically to
those physically prevalent by
transmission I and there are other
rights
those are the most most significant
rights the right to distribute copies
are the most significant rights for
these purposes and of course these
rights only pertain if the work is still
under copyright so one of the first
questions is is any of this material
stuff protected actually starting in
1943 is not the safest course from the
point of view of the duration of
copyright law starting in 1842 is great
because anything that was published
before 1923 is in the public domain
if the work is unpublished like the
markings on the sports more is published
the markings are not covered then the
duration of copyright is the the life of
the author Plus 70 years so you could
have a situation where the the spore is
no longer under copyright but the
markings if they if they are deemed to
constitute in effect an edition of the
work because they tell you how to
perform it and they they are the
performers kind of intellect
it's it's non-trivial that could well
support its own copyright so that's kind
of another layer of possible protection
for concerns to to do it in terms of
what is the subject matter of copyright
it covers literary works
it covers musical compositions
it covers sound recordings so all of
those hours of perform reported about
broadcasts are protected by as well
sound recordings life is a little more
complicated with those but I'll get into
the complications of these not less
there's been specific questions so it is
possible that within the collections of
the harmonic archives particularly if
we're starting if we're talking about
1943 to 1970 there's material that may
well still be under copyright either
with respect to the musical composition
which might have been published first
college in 1923 or were works that are
created starting in 1978
you count from the depth of being the
composer so those those works are are
still going to be protected under
copyright you have the the value added
in terms of the markings of the
performer or of the composer of the
conductor you have even if the work is
in the public domain like its Beethoven
it could be at the addition of Beethoven
is itself the printed Edition might have
editorial value added so that might be
protected and then you've got yet the
next layer of the markings on the
addition of Beethoven soon you have
their various possible loci for
copyright protection so if one starts
from the premise that at least some of
this material is for that bit right the
next question would be who owns it
because if the New York Philharmonic
owns it it's not a problem so if for
example the markings of the performers
of the
the orchestra or the conductor who is a
regular employee of the Philharmonic if
all these are created by employees in
the course of their employment this is
known in copyright law as they work
faithful hotter and what that means is
that the owner of the copyright is not
the individual performer it's the
orchestra the same would go for the
recorded performances by the musicians
that's their job so even though the
recorded performance is gives rise to a
copyright that would be long about to
the individual performers but to the
orchestra okay what about guest
performers the guest conductors yes
soloists if the New York Philharmonic
has a practice of having contracts with
them in which they authorize the
recording the broadcast of their of
their performances or if they give the
archives their their mark duck scores I
don't know to what extent do you have
material for guest performers
use the Philharmonic material and more
contacts and just out of curiosity is
there any agreement or is there in the
past been in agreement about any
ownership rights and those markings from
the non employees no no nothing I think
there was an assumption that it might be
erased those marks might erase today's
the orchestra librarians have decided to
not erase so in the world of just
physical copies this wasn't a problem
now we have a potential problem although
probably fairly slight when we get to
the question of markings not slight when
you get to recorded performances and and
one problem that would present itself is
let's say the the orchestra has contacts
with guest artists those contracts were
entered into way before the digital
period do we consider that any rights
that the guest artists conveyed to the
orchestra apply not only to the
technology
time but also to new modes of
dissemination sometimes contracts say
that all rights in all media now known
or later developed so that that means
take yourself if you don't have a clause
like that in the contract you could have
a problem with the performers ears
might not be this which brings us to the
question of if you have material that is
protected by copyright isn't owned by
the orchestra
if such contracts exists don't convey
the rights
what about fair use barber mentioned
briefly the there are a variety of
exceptions to copyright law but just
talk about fair use which is kind of the
purpose exception there are special
library archive exceptions which allow
for that digitization for preservation
but probably do not allow for unlimited
remote access to entire works there are
some specific executives about public
performances
the educational context but again that
doesn't that lies perfectly there some
of these exceptions might apply some of
the time but what you need is an
exception or combination of exceptions
that will cover everything that you that
you want to do so that brings us to fair
use and under the Copyright Act the
section 107 of the Copyright Act lists a
number of kind of illustrative uses
which are not automatically fair uses
but give you kind of a sense of the
sorts of things that courts might well
considered to be fair uses and these
include things like research commentary
nonprofits educational uses indeed
nonprofit educational uses are also in
the body of section 107 which lists four
factors that courts have to take into
account and those are the nature and
purpose of the use including if it is
for non-profit educational purposes
nature of the work this is a factor it's
pretty much ignored these days the
amount and substantiality but here we're
dealing with entire copy so that's not
really relevant and the fourth factor is
the impact of the use on the actual or
potential market for the work so the
kind of executive summary of fair use is
is the nature of the use something that
is productive in the sense that you are
creating new works particularly of
research scholarship commentary or
nonprofit educational and what it
doesn't have a substitution effect the
work that you are
so those are the those are kind of the
the principal considerations that go
into the balance so on the front end
this is a wonderful public purpose use
and so lots of brownie points on the
purpose of the use that it's really the
back end that raises the question and
this if we consider those those scores
for example or the orchestral parts the
concern on the part of the publishers is
likely to be they don't want the New
York
Archives to become a a free way of
getting copies of the scores or of the
orchestral parts in other words they
don't want Leonard Bernstein's markings
to be kind of a smoke screen we're just
getting a copy of the score of a work
that is still under copyright or
addition that is still under and this is
this would be really true for the
orchestral parts possibly even more true
orchestral parts so if the library
what does what can the archives do to
lessen that concern and thereby
strengthen their fair use argument but
also maintain good relations with the
music publishers because there's lots of
good reasons that we don't want to have
bad relations with music publishers so
one important thing in it I think
they'll probably be talking more about
this is what what can the the archives
do to protect those images from being
copied in a way that makes them usable
substitutes for purchasing or renting
the scores or for the parks and there
are a variety of kind of technological
protection measures I'm not an expert in
technological protection measures but
things that are commonly done not just
here but but in general are this.look
disabling the right click function so
that you you can't make a digital copy
of the content you may not be able to
disable the Print Screen function but
that's going to give you a kind of
credit
as opposed to this digital copy and the
other thing that you can do which is by
no means be truly exclusive I should say
and of it not the other thing is water
parking so that when you the image
itself is displayed might have some data
that appears but most importantly if
that image is further reproduced either
print it out or somehow migrate to
another in digital form that data show
up in a way that effectively obscures
the image so that you've got a copy but
it's not a useable copy so the problem
here is not copying as such it's whether
that's what the quality of the copy is
good enough to substitute or the market
order for those copies so good-faith
efforts on the part of the archives to
address this problem plus the very
strong public policy favoring this kind
of endeavor put together I think make
for a very strong fair use argument part
of the archives that we'll leave it at
that and
in Q&A after we've talked more about
many specific things looking librarian
that the archives are doing to try to
reassure the publishers that this is not
going to be an open season its course I
did
thank you Jane so then into a major use
case I never anticipated that the
research project that Seamus Khan came
to us with doing and sent up here came
to us with material but we don't have
these our subscriber records of demonic
there's really there's a funny
distinction between an archivist
quarters and and I didn't invent that I
simply though didn't want to be the one
to break the tradition when I arrived
there and actually you know the looking
canceled checks for me was really kind
of wonderful to do at companies but I
was I was thrilled when Shane was came
and said we've digitized this stuff if
we do some more we've got a project in
it's if after only two years of making
this available this is the kind of new
and groundbreaking research that's done
I can't imagine what kind of research
would have done you know 10 years 15
years 20 years from now this collection
because it is really sick content heavy
so um so we don't really have any
groundbreaking findings in part because
we're so the mesh still of the data
gathering phase but the you know this
project emerged in part because Don
Randle approached me he said was the
head of the mellon Foundation and said
you know the Philharmonic has this
project this this great archive and
people aren't really doing stuff with it
and so we ended up talking with Barbara
and the Philharmonic and purposive well
you know a lot of it's actually done
already because of the levy foundation
so marginal addition would allow us to
digitize the entire subscriber archive
so the idea behind the project was to
think about who's gone to the
Philharmonic over the last 150 years so
who are the people who are sitting in
the seats at the Philharmonic over the
over sort of long course of history of
New York where are they sitting and
where are they from and this gives you a
sense of some of what the archive looked
like that we ended up turning into a
database so it has people's names where
they sit in the hall and how long they
were there this is from those 60s and
70s
this this on the left is even a sort of
a more an older version of this I think
this is from and you know you see sort
of a person's name and then where they
lived in the city of New York and as you
might imagine turning this into a
database something like an excel file
basically was an enormous challenge it
took thousands of hours of
undergraduates reading through these and
entering than in but the basic insight
was to say maybe we can think of a halt
as
geographic space a set of locations that
people occupy and that we can think
about the relationship between that
Geographic space and other Geographic
spaces like the space of the city and it
might give us a sense of there being
neighborhoods in the hall as just there
are neighborhoods in the city so maybe
people in the Upper East Side sit in a
particular place in the hall for example
but we also have other pieces of
information that could become sort of
interesting for us like what was playing
so are there different kinds of
constituencies for different kinds of
concepts and who's going to what and why
and then there are all these little
natural experiments that happen over the
course of the career of the Philharmonic
so it wasn't the case early in the
Philharmonic history that when you
bought a subscription to Philharmonic
you knew what was going to be played for
example it was only until 1952 something
like that where you would know what you
were going to listen to when you bought
a ticket save months in advance and so
this then provided us an opportunity to
see maybe their own little taste
communities could emerge maybe there are
particular kinds of people who are
interested in only hearing Beethoven and
Mozart and there are other sets of
people who want to hear something for
their little more often part where are
they sitting what are they paying for
their seats where they from in the city
of New York and so just a kind of
preliminary of view of the spatial data
this is from the 1870s and this is
everybody in the hall so that the hall
is Carnegie Hall on our right and on the
left little black boxes where do they
live in the city of New York so if we
took everybody from the hall and
relocated them geographically in New
York where would they live and not
surprisingly it shouldn't be that
surprising for us they're living I'm a
little you know Upper East Upper West
Side area that became Lincoln Center at
the time not really populated with what
we would expect to be near the amount of
subscribers Mary's side relatively empty
as is Chelsea in the Meatpacking
District some of this just has to do
with where people live in the city
overall but some of it also has to do
with the distribution of people
throughout the City of Newark now we
might ask ourselves what about different
areas of the hall
so what does it look like if we take
people who sit and say in the balcony
rather than the entire fall and it's not
that different the balcony people are
pretty pretty widely distributed
throughout the city of New York so
you'll see on the right the balcony sort
of blacked out here so those are all of
the people who sat at the balcony that
year and on the left-hand side we have a
kind of a smattering of where they're
located along the island of Manhattan up
into the Bronx some of them in Brooklyn
and a few even in New Jersey and but we
might compare this by contrast with the
set of people who sit in the boxes that
is the people of the good seats and what
we notice there's a little red dots on
the left is they all live on Fifth
Avenue and this becomes a kind of it's
an interesting finding because you could
imagine thinking about this over time
that is I actually didn't predict this
because I didn't it didn't occur to me
how important a 5th Avenue address or
proximity to Fifth Avenue would be so
you don't actually see deaths spatial
clustering here you don't see an
instance where in everybody lives in the
same neighborhood you see everybody
having a kind of desirability of living
along the Fifth Avenue and again to just
go back that's quite it's it's still the
case that there are a bunch of people on
Fifth Avenue who are sitting up on the
boxes but this mattering is quite
different across the city of New York
and you know this is to just put them
together so the red dots you can see
this is not really any kind of analysis
yet so this is just the beginning so
trying to cry generate some descriptive
data that then might turn into some
broader analysis for thinking about the
places in New York Philharmonic within
the city of New York and we're actually
augmenting the archive from the R Manik
oh I forgot yeah we have a little they
have a Jif so this is a just over the
over the years if we just took the
people in the boxes
located so you can see sort of the
spatial progression it's not it's a
pretty picture that develops but this I
this note I've no big point about this
but we're interested in not making this
sort of view with other caps of New
Yorkers with other elite New Yorkers so
one of the things that we're combining
with this is the Social Register so for
those of you who know the Social
Register it's kind of used to be
referred to as the study book and the
stud book in part because it was used by
families to identify marital eligible
gentlemen for daughters
presumably also daughters for sons and
one of the challenges for for
understanding the Philharmonic in its
place in the broader ecology of New York
is if you don't have other accounts of
the broader ecology of New York you
can't really say with the Philharmonic
is because we only have really one case
and so what we're doing at this point is
also working with another archive this
is the Social Register so this is the
Social Register from 1897 and then it
has a similar bits of information in it
that is it has a name so we have
professor Frank and we know that he
lives in Hoboken New Jersey a member of
the Social Register and it has little
listings of organizations that these
different people are coming from so this
will give us a sort of a portrait of an
elite New York and allow us to juxtapose
some of the people who we think of as
the elite members of the Philharmonic
audience this were sitting in boxes with
other members of the New York the league
to sort of see the role that this
institution has played over say 150
years in constructing relating to elites
within the city of New York so this is
kind of just a brief introduction to
what is a you know hopefully going to be
a large-scale research project once we
get into a lot more of the data analysis
and have more to present than just
pictures in terms of a tiny slice of the
Philharmonic's archive I mean as a
since um the archives of the
Philharmonic the subscriber lists have
to be less than you know probably 0.5%
probably even less but it gives us a
kind of moving portrait of the role of
the Philharmonic and a group of people's
lives and the location of people in New
York and how it is that they relate to a
key cultural institution for the city
this is a page picked at random yeah
probably so in the in the early periods
what is it there's a 20% overlap of the
audiences between the Social Register
and the Philharmonic and that's going to
decline considerably in time over time
so the you know the idea that this is
not you know it's obviously not your
archive but it's it's thinking about not
just thinking about the New York
Philharmonic as an archive of an
institution in New York but as a major
archive about the city of New York that
other things that we have in
relationship to New York's history and
America's cultural history can relate to
and you know since we have names and
addresses we can we can tie people
together so we know what we'll know at
the end of this is these people are the
same you know it's the same person and
to a degree you sort of know this person
had tickets to this concert critical to
play you know here we're who the
soloists were here's how many times have
been played before at the Philharmonic
here's who sat around them if you think
about the neighborhood in terms of the
building that they live in we know
whether or not other people went to
those concerts so it gives you a kind of
like tools for an analysis of the city
of New York and you know not just the
city of New York but one of America's
most important cities and cultural
institutions
yeah so the you know that there's there
are all kinds of challenges the we're
thinking of this is the Social Register
is sort of an elite social group so a
group of Americans that think of
themselves as a kind of a social class
that are a kind of an American
upper-class but not all of them are
wealthy and not all wealthy people are
in the Social Register so one of the
advantages of having addresses is that
you can use addresses to do estimates of
things like wow this is a huge problem
in terms of a data problem so getting
the actual value of each apartment in
the database I mean I don't know how
many people we have but we have two
hundred seventy-five thousand people is
that right fifty thousand people but in
the entire game yeah okay
so just imagine taking up fifty thousand
the value of fifty thousand households
over the over a long term but still we
can come up with some estimates of zip
codes of the average value of houses in
areas and then think about social elite
miss that is the ways in which people
are part of a social community cultural
participation and wealth of neighborhood
and the ways in which those three three
things sort of relate to one another so
that's one of the great advantages of
having the aggressives is not just the
spatial clustering but our capacity to
create estimates of economic inequality
or economic position we can also relate
that to ticket prices so since we have
the ticket price data you can imagine
that in a hall if we think about just
the hall here lots of tickets cost the
same amount of money so it's just it's
not the case that every single seat is
differently priced or that there are
options for seats they're actually set
in their value and you can see so that
when you occupy a seat you have an
option as to where you want to sit now
some of that is going to be personal
taste but some of it also might be the
kind of place you want to be locate
in a hall so it means something
different to want to sit in a box we're
going to a pine than it would to sit in
the orchestra level particularly the
area of the orchestra level that has the
same price structure as the boxes and
that those people are looking for
different kinds of experiences or
they're looking to be part of a
different kind of neighborhood right I
think buy an apartment all over the city
of New York and pay the same amount of
money to move in different neighborhoods
conveys something about the set of
people that I think of myself as being
and that's you know who is it
transcriptions so if you for example
went to this page and you can't read it
because you know it's actually it's not
that easy to read some of these things
there are transcriptions of there is the
page it allow you to search yeah up
until 1952 after 52 weird acting all of
the names just for the privacy of the
the people and then the plan is to have
a rolling sort of a rollout of
additional names as time moves forward
it'll all be available yeah so basically
I mean this work is gonna the the
commitment for doing this work was that
we have a shot at actually doing some
work off of it and then within a year or
so where we'll be putting it online
we're not right now I mean you know as
it as it I mean as it happens the the
data will all be so I mean our our Excel
file our our file will be online at the
Philharmonic well then I'd say about a
year something like that so we don't
have any proprietary control over it in
fact and one of the commitments we made
both to the funders but also to the the
basic idea of the project is to follow
the full Harmonix lead in you know just
radical accessibility so that's not my
database it's a database that I work to
confront construct but that you know you
can you'll be able to download this this
data file yourself and do whatever you
want
yeah
I don't actually
Oh
yeah what happened like how frequently
does BOM lawn get check Dobbs alive or I
wants the strap you know like in years
where the Strauss is being performed it
would be very I mean it would be kind of
interesting there to see these kinds of
things but the other movie two different
halls then this crosses over we have the
layouts and of different halls so you
can even see and it's not really a part
of she study but like you know did they
move into the same kind of neighborhood
within the next call how did those
things rank within signal can be music
to Kearney and then eventually to
anything Fisher I I had area even Fisher
in some ways it's a great kind of
democratization of audience but
yeah and I mean there's a there's a
qualitative part of this project as well
so as much as you know the the first
push was to basically construct this
database and the second has been to so
we've had somebody read through all of
the letters that were written to
philharmonic upon moving to Avery Fisher
and create a chronicle of how it is that
people responded to their new seats and
how they felt about them and what the
complaints were about them so that all
that on the digital archive so there was
a you know there were teams of Columbia
undergraduates this summer who just you
know some who were unfortunate enough to
be working on this something went a
little bit more fun and actually we're
able to read the letters
almost all the letters of complaint
letters this I mean it's actually it's a
real data problem because nobody writes
a letter to say things were fine you
know Seamus they write in to say just
how awful you are and it's you know it's
useful but it creates a kind of a
selection effect problem because you
just don't know if everybody was upset
about the Philharmonic or just you know
people only like to complain so all you
will observe are complaints still the
what it is the way in which people
complain you know the the terms that
they use can become kind of interesting
see comfort is a big issue oh yeah
you're not sending we can follow them
back yeah there's there there were some
spikes and complaints and then there are
always complaints about programming
there's never enough think of it so I
mean that I mean that's what we at least
observe and it's funny because you we
have some data on how frequently things
are played and it doesn't seem as if
there's a huge relationship between the
amount of Beethoven the orchestras
playing and how much
people to complain about the lack of
beta but there's I mean invariably there
are letters that come in that say I
don't know if the New York Philharmonic
remembers that there are composers named
Mozart Beethoven Schubert and you should
play them this was a and it was a big
complaint with the beginning of the
Princeton they're actually the you see a
lot of these so I mean you know there's
going to be a little bit of you know
data analysis pyrotechnics to this but
important is also to put it in the
context of the broader archive and to
think about is it the case that we find
evidence that when people write in about
their seat being changed that they're
concerned about the dynamics that we
identify as important I'm not sitting in
the right kind of place because I like
to be in this kind of place if we don't
observe that we don't have a lot of
external validity for our claims so it's
really useful to have this broader
archive to be able to evaluate the sets
of arguments that we want to make
sustained
well the the digital archives is all the
repository in the back end is alfresco
open source ECM it's commercial open
source product there is a community
version that's free to download and
using try but we are subscribing to the
enterprise stack for an alfresco the
front-end is all open source PHP and
codeigniter framework so fresco has a
REST API for Java pack web scripts so
it's very easy to get data in and out of
alfresco all these are open source
platforms and open code so you know it
allows us the flexibility to migrate for
it in future or some differ in the
future if we wanted to and it also
allows us to you know share techniques
that we used so that we can build
community around the products one of the
main reasons we chose
even launched internally within for
Monica to serve as the basic repository
for everything that goes on today for
all the more digital that happens today
it's part of that process of the
marrying of the past with the present so
you see that end and the alfresco of
course has versioning material as when I
think Sean's at Dartmouth is happiest
when more digital items are saved to the
Internet can open them ten years later
sometimes the date will just change so
what is the real date of that document
howdy we haven't validated December that
time so an alfresco has rigid control
that we keep is critical and actually
then identifying the archival copy
oh there's an institution
it's going to be well you see what it's
doing is it's replacing this this sort
of ad hoc in turn a network system that
is currently in place within your
organization so it offers an institution
a lot more security when I'm staff
members leave when they
there's all kinds of that just to follow
up on that you know a fedora fedora
Commons is a very common thing you'd see
implemented for these types of projects
in libraries archives museums
universities we chose an enterprise
content management or more traditional
dam type system because it is a
traditionally a system like alfresco is
used for storing digital content that's
being produced every day in an
organization so instead of starting from
what's being produced today and storing
all that stuff and working in it on a
daily basis the way most companies and
use cases do with alfresco we started
with our digitization project and now
we're working forwards so we'll create
one repository that will incorporate
form digital material creative material
things that were generated today
alongside historical digitized material
and that's really important for
sustainability because that means it's
the digitization project is not
separated from the daily business of the
organization in order for the
organization to have any control over
there you know the intellectual
documents things that are produced by
our employees you know this system will
have to live and that's part of the
overall strategy for sustainable
No
it is but like any other kind of
repository there are you know there are
these there's web publishable which then
makes it available there's they are
certain kinds of documents that won't
probably be made public for seven years
which is to deal with people's health
those are a different kind of thing
but we captured
so this there's nothing you can do worse
than making something available
I don't know sango's
and that the parts are much scarcer and
sports scores are in most public
libraries parts parts under copyright
there may be only 20 second world so
they are much more tightly controlled
than a scores
material is very I guess it would come
in and what they would they could make
plenty from how they could benefit
financially but is the actual content
play
or more as a copywriter hole than the
hole
the market
very
varies down
is it really
other other other examples research that
music orchestra
in music hitman project Jets invincible
well or is it made mainly an access the
ad on his axe really in that case access
anybody but no one is under 70 parts
before I mean so we will hear from
around the world that you know someone
named is responsible in unison and
Liverpool they're responsible for their
community Orchestra of a bully in
Beethoven's fifth symphony and you know
that is a very difficult thing to do
only source I think that we found where
where musicians markings from the
website are being we think should go and
so it's and
anecdotal responses
flavors
so we're open
they always sent somebody into the
archives to look at how monarch dinner
now we're excited for
I think the other thing we thought we
were trying to do is to work with a
honey I have to say it's me being in the
darkness after Jeanie
like we went through this language of
what we're going to post in the letter
that I was going to send up to the
publishers and then I said to Jane
we're like this if they tell me of teeth
and now I'll take it down and she said
no he won't
and it really makes a difference to have
some money in your corner that says even
if somebody talking wrong so I have to
say it I couldn't hear a little bit of
publishers
the store's been up for three years
there is tremendous nervousness about
parts watermark some of those and we're
working on the great things about having
these things available online and having
Google Analytics visiting credential
track usage very very well instead of
you know
wanted to come back to us with a blanket
that week and I have to say frankly if
we do monitor and we see we socially
extraordinary activities from China
today's in August and we were nearly
beside ourselves because all of a sudden
that daily rates went up to 10,000 new
10,000 people were just on that side and
couldn't figure out what was going on
and then we learned this is how well we
communicate in the Philharmonic that the
phone I had noticed in China auditions
for a huge Shanghai conservatory but
what was fascinating in terms of the
Shanghai conservatory and for the
piranhas we could see how broadly people
within China were interested in the
program
it's a minute valuable there's so many
ways
but we'll see and I really do want to
work with publishers I think the right
publishers like to work some of this
material even if it was behind some sort
of a payroll that people could read that
word
first year of this crowdsourcing
we thought we didn't have crowdsourcing
is available on the photographs we
haven't publicized it because the
ability to do a lot of crowdsourcing on
photographs seems to the more you call
up the slower it gets so we need to
adjust and work on this a bit
and we think that is the way that we're
going together I those of you trying to
identify every member of an ensemble or
orchestras in worse than going front row
left to right second row except for the
guy standing either left or right and so
to be able to put face taking little box
alone on everybody is just it's just a
great food but how to deal with more
digital photographs from last night's
concert
it's basically
turning into a movie we have to figure
out how to do a bad suggestion into or
digital repository and
and the kind of sword goes out I mean
you know some would say Alan Gilbert
maniax October 23rd 2013 but
so ideally what we'd like to do is to
use some facial recognition software
it's being developed so that when we put
into place and overlay that to help the
students
and then Mitch has been involved with an
incredible project that the only
University that we think it's going to
turn into it's not the immediate goal of
it but to actually have recognized
the marketing program because we do have
scores that are marked by several
different conductors and
this is a challenge
new software could go through there will
be a Beethoven 7th in the next launch
the materiality of Beethoven seventh
this work by both Martin
Oh
here in
yeah
Oh video will be then it would be
overwhelming in in 30 years I mean we
create so much video now you know what
we used to interview all these artists
and now within your tape office artisan
interviews and we do have a lot of
television going back to the city
Bernstein but in and that all is just a
matter of negotiation of Rights in this
sort of thing which which is you just
you know I don't think there's any fair
game especially on audio for video but I
think it's
we just but then going forward I think I
think videos be next midnight today
looked we just did a little exercise
where we looked at we know what people
are interested in researching and so we
looked the type of documents they need
and so we looked at what we were
creating this season and how much of
that material the people will be using
how welcome to make it available to 50
years from now and I have to say
it's a scary proposition it's one thing
to preserve something it's another to
make it available
so that's why we are being repository
means
so even if it's a video format that goes
out of date we just automatically start
to find very post things we have a lot
of experience with that with the audio
you know the earliest digital format the
philharmonic adopted was the beta tape
in the early eighties
because that's digital bit and we think
that digital now sometimes is so
sensitive that it would only transfer on
a sea machine accorded so so
we've been dealing abalone on our credit
formats now for a long time so at least
we're not mindset
doesn't exist anymore
and engineers tell me oh yes I've never
tried no we say it all but we just we
just had a project that the city mayor
one of the last seen America's treasures
France was given to us to preserve the
Bernstein television programs and so we
got all the original television programs
out of CBS FOX Los Angeles and it was
one of I mean where we are now in that
time period they should only last about
30 years 40 years and so it 50 years
would prove beyond their lifespan and
said we
last fantasy
they're so excited to see ya Foundation
wasn't here but she's here to see what
she learns about this stuff and it's
really a real treat
besides effective fundus it's really
really free
you